hoy nueva de Eli Está De Fiesta
oficiales de policía miembros del
gobierno e incluso la prensa nacional se
han reunido en este auditorio para
celebrar el regreso al país de unas
estatuas que representan divinidades
hindúes algunas de las cuales datan del
siglo 11
fueron hurtadas de templos de India y
hasta este momento estaban exhibidas en
museos de Estados Unidos y Australia
[Música]
el gobierno indio se ha dedicado a
exigir la restitución de estos objetos
que fueron robados hace décadas
constatamos con orgullo que nuestros
incansables esfuerzos
han empezado a dar sus frutos
el Primer Ministro narendra modi
ha convertido el regreso de nuestros
ídolos
de nuestras antigüedades en una de sus
prioridades cada vez que se desplaza al
extranjero
desde la llegada del poder de 2014 cerca
de 230 obras como esta le ha sido
devueltas a India sin contraprestación
financiera una vez recuperadas por las
autoridades son restituidas a los
templos de donde provenían originalmente
cuando no son reclamadas se exhiben aquí
en esta galería que abrió sus puertas en
2019 el Museo de los objetos confiscados
en el corazón de la capital India anil
kumartiguari es el director de la
sección de antigüedades de la agencia
arqueológica India
Esta es una escultura que representa
Buda de pie viene de la ciudad de gallo
después de largas negociaciones Estados
Unidos no la de milenarias en algunos
casos estas esculturas en mármol bronce
o latón encontradas en el extranjero
pero también en el territorio indio
fueron robadas recientemente o antes de
la independencia durante siglos los
templos hindúes estuvieron en la mira de
los saqueadores que alimentan el tráfico
de arte algunas piezas pueden ser
revendidas por varias decenas de miles
de euros
este escándalo de enviar de manera
ilegal estatus fuera de India existe
desde hace mucho tiempo buscó bajarle
llagas la historia ha demostrado que los
reyes persas ya por ese entonces se
habían apropiado de estos objetos
[Música]
Y claro con el Imperio británico se
exportaron muchas antigüedades e
Inglaterra
sacadas clandestinamente del país las
piezas se encuentran en museos o en
colecciones privadas de Europa o Estados
Unidos para encontrarlas India cuenta
con una unidad de policía que se dedica
a la protección de estos trabajan desde
la ciudad de chenai en el tami ladú dos
mil kilómetros al sur de Nueva Delhi a
finales de 2022 la brigada recuperó
estas estatuas diez años después de que
hubieran sido hurtadas de un templo de
la región estos dos pequeños huecos se
utilizan para fijar los ídolos a un
soporte para que no se caigan durante
una procesión esto Solo puede observarse
en los ídolos que se conservan en los
templos nunca en estatuas que estén en
la casa de un particular con sus 47.000
templos el estado de tamildad es una El
Dorado para los traficantes de arte en
cuatro décadas está brigada Ha logrado
encontrar cerca de 4.500 piezas
esculturas y también muchas pinturas
pero los ladrones a menudo consiguen
ocultar su botín durante años
los ladrones entierran las estatuas o
las pinturas para esconderlas por lo
general hacen eso para después poder
sacar las clandestinamente las ocultan
durante uno o dos años el tiempo
necesario para que las piezas adquieran
valor una vez que consideran que han
alcanzado un buen precio las
desentierran las venden en el extranjero
Y obtienen una buena ganancia
muchas veces estas investigaciones se
llevan a cabo gracias a los informantes
de los pueblos y desde hace algunos años
unos voluntarios también se lanzaron a
la cacería de objetos indios Villa y
cumar es el cofundador del India Pride
project una red integrada por 300
voluntarios que hacen parte de la
diáspora recorren los museos y se
infiltran en las exposiciones de arte y
en la subastas en busca de indicios que
permitan localizar las estatuas robadas
procedemos de la siguiente manera Esta
es una foto tomada por uno de nuestros
voluntarios en una galería de arte Y
esta es una foto de los archivos del
instituto francés de chery damos las
mismas imperfecciones las mismas
facturas eso demuestra que es
exactamente el mismo objeto pero no
siempre es fácil obtener la restitución
Una vez que se ha identificado que el
objeto fue robado
esta estatua de bronce está a la venta
en el catálogo de crisis no existe
ningún documento que demuestre que salió
ilegalmente de India
le pertenecía a ctlu un comerciante de
arte pero ahora se sabe que ZTE luz
hacía contrabando de arte
insultante ver que nuestros dioses son
considerados como una simple mercancía
ver que las personas los compran en las
subastas o verlos al borde de una
piscina o en las habitaciones de las
personas ricas de Europa y América
en diciembre pasado con la ayuda de la
policía y ya y logró evitar una subasta
durante una venta de crisis en París
según una estimación de la UNESCO 50.000
objetos robados de los templos hindúes
estarían dispersos por el mundo